hi juliana hi
good morning
good morning how are you really good
how was your night it's cold right now
great
freezing cold last night yeah
you're still in love with skid row all
right i mean someone was getting wrong
what do you love about it honey i love
basketball it's the fact that i can make
what went up in the smoke so tasty
treats
you can what
going up in the air and you have to
smoke like tasty treats
people are getting killed and murdered
and fentanyl ods everything every night
i smoked some poison last night too
and i was like i need a pound myth and
they're like really liking us
what kind of poison did you did you
smoked i smoked wrapped with
what rat poison rat poison yeah
it helps it helps loosen up excrement
shins from your bowels
from being wrapped between medical tip
and so it was like
and i'm like whoa i needed up the right
rat right and he was like
[ __ ] kept a wicked wife you're trying
to have a stroke
and i was like okay
i'm tasty
i stayed up and it was so cold i got
when he burped and fed all at once so i
was like well that's a laptop you
experiment with a lot of different drugs
yes i do you do
you tried pcp i love it
you tried it you tried crack i love it
and uh crystal meth is your favorite i
think right yes it's a very formidable
affordable cancer treatment
it's a cancer treatment yes it's for
pain level well i do find it interesting
that nobody's getting sick down here you
don't see anyone with flus or colds or
covalent yes i love it because they have
a real vaccine
and it's a one time one shot johnson and
johnson
and i got it and i felt i was amazingly
all of a sudden like it was just
amazing like i was completely free of
coordinating
you got the kobe
unless you're doing something
responsible it was so great i put my
medical name tag in my backpack put it
on my back and i was like yeah i got two
20 dollars
so so back to the street drugs which
ones do you not like i do not like
overdose bags because it makes me think
i'm gonna do something wrong
have you odd on fentanyl
never
have you tried fentanyl
yes
and i was like
that's cream out of the funny legs ones
baby
she's like he's right
yeah so you're in a
particularly interesting mood this
morning what did you smoke or i don't
know rat poison so right this is rat
poison that we're saying on you
i i smoked rat poison but i smoked a
shrimp stick with my friend first oh
and i actually gave him a poison bag and
he was like
i got hit by a car right so i'm like it
says bicycle's worth like two thousand
five hundred dollars
and so like is that a two jinkies five
hundred dollars and you've been up all
night
yeah
what do you do on that do you turn dates
do you do oh yeah i get [ __ ] all the
time in green fight every day
someone else come everywhere so i'm like
little kim i'm just right there right
before you
blend
how many how many dates will you do
oh i'll make a way to be awake i was
awake for 2025 days before and i had to
take him to a rested area and they had
to give me a pillow i had to rock him to
sleep after two thousand days yeah i
believe it he's having two days because
i was like if i go to school and i take
over to some med shots like i was like
like all these news everywhere because
it's from my hypoglycemia
so you're not always in this mood but
sometimes you are and i it's just maybe
it's the rat poison that's making you do
this it is and the rap voice is like
because bitter scalp vampire
and i was like
oh okay
hello good morning how are you all i am
the timing
of the cigarette
fast burn
and i put my cigarette in it first and i
accidentally put my cigarette in it
right and i had no idea what it was and
so i'm writing it i'm smoking it and i'm
bringing it into my lungs
and i'm like
that's the best orgasm i've ever tasted
and they're like wet is like slipping
falling down can get up
so the heat shot was like amazing so
some of these drugs help you with your
sexual
injury yes i think the cover 19 shot
cured me from the kubernetes
no but i'm talking about your sexual
enjoyment yes it took away all the
sloppies i can come that was ugly out of
my lungs because my daughter's there
like
i'm talking about the mmm or the crystal
meth or the uh rat poison it's right
yes it's a testifying treatment for it
rat bites
it's a little bit of
at least with the rat urine and it makes
aromatic cleaning from the bloodline of
moccasin water bloodsticks
and i had gotten a venomous
poisonous snake stopped in my lungs
before
and that's what it is is going around my
body like this is your life down here on
skid row just like an endless party it
is it's supposed to be celebrating
cancer research funds or what happened
to carly
and carlo and i'm like they're at the
ritz carlos do you have a boyfriend do
you have a boyfriend down here yes you
do yes he gave me an outfit and it looks
like this and this i'm imagining
it's nice you have somebody
yes
he he allows you to go out in these
dates and yes he told me what to
celebrate every day has two exact rings
one big and one small and one smart and
one big so that we cherish each other
because why wouldn't we have two little
halos for our daughters or our sons who
would like to present them with the
wreath
i've got you now can't move your arms
and go anywhere can you so you're
starting to breathe last night was very
cold it's probably in the high 30s low
40s
you're in a tent all night
yes and i was like trying to stay awake
keeping my blood warm
and i realized this because it's called
refrigerated
mix for
them so that they cherish your scent
like they're like oh something is new in
their movie
and i heard rat's eggs are contagious
contaminants of cover 19 and that's what
the show is about
and
leaves and soft shell egg that looks
like a clean
piece of penicillin peel
and that's called a snake venom egg from
a rat
and that's when the other fats drink
human drink
and they say we're not contagious we are
invited giuliano let me ask you some of
the questions i asked everyone else i
interviewed what were you like in high
school i was very fat
yeah this girl there was you were very
white fat you were biggest girl or what
really yeah
and i said nobody cares about me because
my entire family died on his ship they
drowned
and then my dad had me cloned to bring
them back to life
and then
i found out later that it was all a hoax
to get me to birth his babies and it
keeps [ __ ] me and my [ __ ] and he
got plastic surgery and he looked so
perfect and i told him don't cut your
dick off but i understand you used to
dress like a
woman and you had your your
dick pushed out
and you got balls and stuff
it's easy to give yourself a look of
classic beauty
but his people was standing next to him
and i said you're here forever
what is he doing here
so i said
that's your girlfriend
i want to turn yourself into a man
i was like she hit my homies with
her car
and then she got scared and cut my
friend's dick off and glued it to her
tried to make me suck it and then we're
gonna razor it off and my throat
diamond what to
cause they're so cold right like what
would you want a big bob what are you
worried about are you scared of anything
no i'm never scared of anything you're
never scared of anything never are you
ever you ever get depressed or anything
you're just i'm never getting depressed
you always seem i see you every day
pretty much and you always seem in a
pretty good mood oh i'm always in a
great mood it just takes a lot of energy
for my calories to catch up to my body
so so the weight that you lost since
high school you lost out
getting the plastic diet surgery
of having them remove my stomach and my
intestines so everything goes down into
my mouth takes seven seconds to reach my
anus they call it hypoglycemia
because there's
tarantulas that pull down the food and
they infect their bodies with it because
anybody understands what a tarantula is
it pulls the food immediately and puts
it on top of it like a wig
and then it moves its senses into the
food and rubs it all over it like oh my
god if i get somebody to give me some
cream for a day eating some milk and
honey it would be called meat
meow
and eat
honey
and i lick it it looks like caramel and
it's called drizzled
or delivered over a pie and they call it
pumpkin spicy
and it's available on your calendars
let's put it on the cake
and they call it pineapple crush let me
call it now
let me spike it let me ask you one of
the questions i asked you last time see
if you have a different answer what uh
if this one does
alcohol i'm sorry it's like 105.00
alcohol it's like liquid um
like a caramel
what do you think of it
diamond what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
life
um i've learned to always let any man
cream primer dinner i'm like you never
know when you're gonna need a sperm
sample as well i'm sorry say that again
i said i always recommend to get cream
pied first
cream pie is what is when they take a
pie and they just throw your face
and then call you a liar on the bone
and make a big disaster and they're like
maybe you told me to that we're acting
and we're playing another class because
you're like we want a whipped cream with
bikini and she was like i got strawberry
and whipped cream um
and then in real life i had gotten a
belt wrapped around my throat and i was
whipped
and so i was like oh my god i killed my
real friend my pimp
what do i do
and they were like are you serious
i don't think i remember your face here
i used a dog that crawled out of the
photographer and then put her boyfriend
in the dog fur and then glued it
together with all-purpose glue i can't
seem to find my glitter did you take my
two glue pistols and then i took the
noodles and i put them in my nipples and
i was like milk
everywhere every cereal he's like
okay
that's he got me right now
what
and he's just like
tiffany one two five eight one two four
six they have a full size germanium to
make it like hot tubs right
somebody's locked in the bathroom right
so i'm like i'm the engineer i love drug
dealers smoking big ass is not loud
anymore and he's like i'm someone in
love with you
somebody took my dick on box i said get
a clone and grow it and let the ball
does that come out your anus and let the
dick come out the top of you because
everyone is vomiting
what goes on in these public washrooms
that are out here on skid row everything
they pulled me about the floor and they
dusted up my shoulders and said we are
microphone ready for you diamond
juliana
do i call you giuliana or diamond you
may call me janky blood diamond demon
some sister summer's ladies i'll stick
with giuliana um juliana
is my identical twin sister and i'm
diamond identical
tell me about what goes on in the
bathrooms
down here sex and lots of dry burying
and hammering to my nails
like they want to make sure it's pressed
on for real that's really what i think
they're for yes and then hammers our
benedict are used to move the flint
without touching the dryers and so i was
told that i can say things like
coalition 4th alameda parking lot is now
open for pedestrians who would like to
purchase some parking ticket lots
they're coming around checking
everybody's cars for identification for
a fear of theft
so i said their fear of theft is that
there's somebody outside a new little
girl
she looks a big girl but i see my mother
and she's like a [ __ ]
she gave birth to me through my father
and he's a milking kitty and he raised
me on dick [ __ ]
instead of breast milk
and when i got to school it was to his
amazement why he can't hear so they call
them most deaf
and he came and told me hey they fixed
me give me a liposuction i told you my
friends bought me full of a bunch of
frisbee and we were at boot camp
together i was like yeah we're the ones
that were like yeah were you telling
shape and stuff
and i was like
he had a sex change and feels guilty
about coming inside the condom because
he's like i put it over there he's
better than picking up a drink or
something but i left it down everybody
dropped the bottle of peels right
there like memory facing pills
and it really is affected but it's
called
anthrax
and it's not allowed in my party so can
you please collect the yellow pill for
me because i don't want him to lose
weight i only understand like 20 of what
you're telling me but yeah right you're
fun to listen to it it's so difficult to
hear what they're saying on my radio and
you're fun to listen to regardless thank
you
i wish i'd stopped making the extra jar
julia thank you so much for coming by
again you're welcome i'll give you some
lunch money you need some food in your
belly yes
number one we're america's most wanted
i'm sorry i said number one where
america's one
you